es gibt ja noch einen anderen account
das ist nämlich ihrer und das ist der
her
der ist ihnen tatsächlich in einer
heftigkeit um die ohren geflogen wie sie
es vermutet hätten oder nicht liegt aber
vor ich war schon so oft gegenstand von
schütz storms und und skandalen weil ich
was gesagt habe und ich bekenne mich
insofern schuldig ich sage eben oft was
ich wirklich denke und wovon ich
überzeugt bin
und mitunter gibt dann eben auch mal was
drauf und leute sehen es anders aber ich
meine wenn ich jetzt nur
stromlinienförmig sein wollte und vorher
erstmal eine umfrage machen was ankommt
ja wie soll man dann debatten anstoßen
vielleicht darf ich das kurz kurz
erläutern gemeint ist weil ich glaube
dass die aufregung damit zusammenhängt
dass man hier das bedauerlicherweise in
den falschen hals bekommen haben weil es
gemeint die klimaziele sind ja
unstreitig und ich bin ein kritiker
unserer bundesregierung weil wir in
deutschland die klimaziele nicht
erreichen aber die weltweit höchsten
kosten für die vermeidung von co2
produzieren wir brauchen einen anderen
weg und da bin ich jetzt bei folgenden
punkt menschen wie ich habe mal
politikwissenschaft studieren
ich weiß nicht ob die brennstoffzelle
oder der elektroantrieb oder
synthetische kraftstoffe im
verbrennungsmotor oder was auch immer
was der überlegene antrieb ist aber in
der politik sind des politologen
soziologen die nie was
naturwissenschaftliches gemacht haben
die darüber entscheidungen treffen ich
glaube wir müssen in deutschland
demokratisch als studenten schüler
politologen und journalisten über ziele
streiten aber bei dem weg hin zu den
zielen
da müssen wir wieder stärker ingenieuren
und technikern vertrauen weil wir dann
schneller die klimazonen das sind die
profis das sind die bodenstation
wenn man
das ist meine position seit vielen
jahren dann habe ich schon wahlkämpfe
bestritten als ob wir haben in
deutschland das problem dass die politik
sehr stark ein greift in das konkret
technische und ich würde es besser
finden
übrigens bin ich mit frau neubauer da
einer meinung wenn wir so eine art
modell bekäme es gibt klare regeln wie
bestimmen wir demokratisch aber danach
vertrauende wieder aufheben
die kreativität von ingenieuren weil
wenn die politik eingreift gibt es
paradox ergebnis ich nenne ihn ein
paradoxes ergebnis aber wir müssen
schnell sein weil ich sehe die pochen
der halsschlagader von louis sehe ich
dies hier ist ja ich finde zum beispiel
es paradox dass wir in deutschland jetzt
ein plant im staatshaushalt 200
millionen euro die deutschland an
strafen zahlen soll weil wir die co2
einsparziele nicht erreichen aber es
gibt genau null euro für die
gebäudesanierung an damit wir dort im
wärmebereich co2 einsparen wie viel
besser wäre es statt die strafen zu
zahlen würden wir die sanierung von
gebäuden fördern
dann würden dort konkret co2 einsparen
ziele erreichen was für das weltklima
tun und mit dem geld vernünftig umgehen
ok verstanden guter punkt trotzdem
gemüsebauer restaurants
ein einsatz wie der der ja aus einem
interview mit den kollegen von bild am
sonntag zunächst mal enorm ist und sie
haben es dann auch nochmal nochmal bei
twitter veröffentlicht
warum hat euch das so auf die palme
gebracht genau dieser satz weil er so
eine vermeintlich sagt vermeintlich
arrogante attitüde dahinter steckt na ja
da gibt es ganz viele gründe vielleicht
vorangestellt mich regen viele sachen
auf die twitter post von christian
lindner
vielleicht noch ein bisschen energie da
ist aber die großen themen sind
natürlich irgendwie andere meinen
respekt da sieht man natürlich da hat
anscheinend ja denn aber das grundlegend
falsch verstanden wenn mein haus brennt
muss ich kein profi sein um zu verstehen
dass mein haus brennt ich brauche dann
profis die mir helfen bis zu löschen so
sein das ist dass er überhaupt straße
tragen
wenn wir sagen liebe politik ist es fünf
nach zwölf
bitte hört auf die wissenschaft macht
was ist euer job beziehen wir uns in
aller in aller direktheit auf die profis
die ja auch in form von zb in 23.000
sein dass verführte hinter unschön und
sagen es ist richtig ist es gut dass man
auf die straße gehen dieser dieser ja
latent arrogante unterton von von diesem
posten ist ein bisschen lächerlich in
meinen augen ich glaube wir haben
wichtigeres als die gibt es ja noch mehr
also als die sache mit den profis von
jugendlichen kann man nicht erwarten
dass sie bereits alle globalen
zusammenhängen dass technisch sinnvolle
und ökonomisch nach machbare kennen
das ist ja auch genau diese attitüde ja
aber da muss ich jetzt echt sagen was
ist daran falsch
was ist daran falsch kann man von
kindern erwarten dass sie alle globalen
zusammenhänge das technisch sinnvolle
und das ökonomisch machbaren ich
behaupte herr lanz sie und ich sehe noch
nicht mal alle globalen zusammenhänge
aber genau deswegen schneiden
ich sage aber einspruch euer ehren genau
deswegen doch genau deswegen doch weil
ich das nämlich auch nicht kenne
würdigsten auch nicht zum vorwurf machen
dass sie es auch nicht leben aber es ist
doch das nicht ich mache keinen vorwurf
machen vor weiblichen laub folgendes
hinaus muss er die debatte in mehreren
ebenen sehr die erste ebene ist wir
können nicht einerseits
unterrichtsausfall beklagen und dann
gibt es politiker die das
schuleschwänzen heilig sprechen und ich
glaube die nehmen sie nicht ernst
nämlich die politiker gegen die sie
demonstrieren die aus dem parlament
heraus kommen sich bei ihnen ein rein
und sagen toll ist wirth schule
geschwänzt die reden ihnen doch in
wahrheit nach dem mund die nehmen sie
doch gar nicht ernst und deshalb sage
ich einsatz für klimaschutz für
demokratie finde ich wunderbar aber
schon das schwänzen außerhalb der
schulzeit weil auch arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer streiken nicht während
der arbeitszeit sollen ihre sondern
demonstrieren nicht in ihrer arbeitszeit
sondern die streiken und ein streik ist
gesetzlich geregelt deshalb glaube ich
schulschwänzen können wir nicht für
welches edle motive auch immer
bagatellisieren
können sich jetzt so zurecht legen was
sie aber in diesem typen aber darauf
beziehen stellen sie ja dazu sagen die
die schülerinnen und schüler in relation
zu der kompetenz klimatologische und
klima wissenschaftliche zusammenhänge zu
verstehen dass aufweist
wenn sie sagen sie finden die klima
streiks gut dass ich finde es gut wenn
junge menschen sich für das klima
zusammentun und laut werden dann hätte
das ja auch in einem separaten tweet gut
unterkommen können denn sie unabhängig
davon finden und das ist ja ein
berechtigter einwand die die technik
denn da die wissenschaft dahinter ist
was wir profis hat auch übrigens nie
jemand irgendwie dementiert hätte man
das schon noch mal anders aufbereiten
können man auf diesem tweet geht in
erster linie heraus ihr junger mensch
hat eigentlich keine ahnung und dass sie
es wagen eigenen stimme zu haben ist
eigentlich ein bisschen over the top
das ist gar nicht meine intention das
ist gar nicht meine intention ich bin
auf einen umstand hinweisen kann es
allen ernstes so seien seit jahren
sprechen über die versäumnisse beim
klimaschutz mit mit langen reden der
erste antrag der fdp in der neuen
legislaturperiode im bundestag ging um
klimaschutz weil wir so wie wir es
bisher machen es für zu teuer und
unwirksam halten
und jetzt wird diskutiert und sich
empört 150 zeichen das heißt also eine
premiere sind jetzt schon weiter nähe
sind gemischten waren es wird ja immer
noch ausgelesen interpretiert 150
zeichen und ich halte das unabhängig von
dieser aktuellen debatte für ein problem
unserer politischen kultur dass wir auf
der ebene von zvi zum soft empören
unterhalten und gar nicht mehr der
verlässlichsten doch diese maschine auch
ja du mir leid er entschuldigt habe sie
füttern doch diese maschine mit sie ist
auf diese art und weise verglich können
sie doch andere nicht vorwerfen dass sie
dasselbe moment
moment da kann man in googles app den
den zuschauerinnen und zuschauern
empfehlen ich stelle meine position da
und wer sich an ihr stößt kann mal
schauen was meinte er denn und dann
findet er zum beispiel bei zeit online
einladen text wo ich das erläuterung
aber jetzt mal jenseits von dieser
empörungswelle ich gebe gerne ein
stehendes ziel ab möge man sich an mir
reiben
das belebt die demokratie jetzt aber zur
sache worum es mir geht die diese um die
sache um die es hier geht ist
ich glaube wir brauchen keine
zusätzlichen klimatologischen
erkenntnisse
ich glaube dass wir auch nicht noch mal
neu darauf hinweisen müssen dass es den
klimawandel gibt seinem ac siena profi
und daneben kann klima woher kommt dann
also dass die argumentation aber wir
haben doch die pariser klimaziele
der große haken helena sie dass wir die
pariser klimaziele haben bringt dem
planeten nichts wie sohnes bringt meiner
generation nicht das bringt den menschen
den milliarden menschen heute und dem
klimaschutz zu erreichen
wir müssen was dafür tun effektive
klimaschutz maßnahmen einleiten um diese
wirken zu können und jetzt sind sie
natürlich zusammen weil ich ja der
auffassung bin wir brauchen einen
anderen klimaschutz
also ich könnte also ich bin ja kein
klimawandel oder im gegenteil ich bin
der auffassung wir brauchen effizientere
wege als jetzt klimaziele zu erreichen
der erreichen sie gegenwärtig nicht und
da ist mein vorschlag zum beispiel dass
wir dafür sorgen dass wir nicht so eine
verbotsdebatte führen also ihre partei
die grünen die wollen ja drei flüge pro
mensch und jahr
david hasselhoff wäre nicht hier mit
dieser politik die drei flüge pro jahr
würde ich sage es polemisch dass sich
niemand von verboten gebrochen deshalb
sieht gerade in die batterie nicht so
handeln im moment nicht mehr verboten
sprechen wollen können wir auch essen
und sagen
sie seien willkommen so ein bisschen weg
von diesem von diesem tweet demokratie
ist um die sache
ich finde das gesicht man um diese zu
denken man darf nur auf die straße gehen
oder man darf nur protestieren was
themen angeht wo man experte ist ich
meine damals haben wir doch auch eine
demo haben viele demonstrieren waren
nicht alle atomphysiker man musste auf
dinge aufmerksam machen dürfen ich bin
ja viel widerstand komme muss ich sagen
sie verdrehen mir die worte im mund
jeder dafür alles demonstrieren und
parlamente entscheiden demokratisch aber
unser problem ist dass wir
technologische wege finden müssen um die
klimaziele zu erreichen und das kann ich
nicht stören
entsprechend stören amerika machen dies
hat das wunder muss einer sich nicht
stellen und das ansprechen das brauchen
wir dann mit registrieren
auch in den staaten dass sich politiker
störung eigentlich nur die stirn
überragen in jeder lage und sie haben
selber so gesang frage und politiker
stören die technologie hat sie jetzt
herten haben gerade gesagt politiker
störer die fachliche technologische hof
arbeiten
diese gibt es nicht was was man machen
könnte darauf machen die aufmerksam
so ist es nicht starten auch nicht an
das bestehende schüler und studenten auf
sagen was passiert nichts machen
sie bringen sich um ihren sich doch als
emotionaler prozess daraufhin richtet
schluss mit dem kanonen schluss mit den
gewehren waffen die politiker machen
nichts stimmt und hier scheint es nicht
anders in deutschland
warum und ehrlich ich gebe jeden tag
inter versucht immer um die politik wie
finden sie den krieg und wie finden sie
das
dass es mit der mauer ich bin
entertainer die politik verstören immer
dabei auch weiter stören
ich kann nur sagen lesen sie einfach die
kommentare nicht einschläft zu bestimmen
sie können schreiben dass gewalt macht
seine reaktion provozieren sie könig auf
twitter jener verschreiben woran sie
nicht selber glauben nun reaktionskette
also ziehen
warum weil er reaktion dass wille das
ist unser präsident auf twitter bitte
[Applaus]
ganz interessant was hier gerade
passiert und ich finde david hasselhoff
hat einen punkt und das meine ich jetzt
gar nicht als angriff gegen sie sondern
die art und weise wie wir politik
mittlerweile begreifen er hat doch recht
wenn er sagt es geht um reaktion es geht
darum schnell zu sein es geht darum als
politiker ganz früh morgens eben die
seine botschaft rauszuhauen damit du
möglichst den ganzen tag stattfindet ich
habe hier manchmal leute sitzen nicht
sie jetzt aber andere die sagen weißt du
wenn ich die wahl habe im morgenmagazin
zu sein oder abends broich in der
sendung gehe ich immer ins morgenmagazin
die begründung ist interessant weil dann
finde ich mit dem was ich dort sage den
ganzen tag statt das der punkt ja und
diese und diese und das was sie dort
geschah abgesetzt haben ist ja auch der
hat er doch recht ist im grunde etwas
sie wollen rein in diese debatte
sie wollten der reaktion haben lief das
hätten die sich einmal gut sparen können
ja sie wollten sie wollten reinigen
diese debatte und und da kommt jetzt der
punkt an dem ich diese jungen leute so
so interessant finde die sagen weißt du
was dieses spiel dieses da die bösen da
die guten da die verbots partei da die
partei gesagt das wollen wir nicht dann
wieder diese vorwürfe ihr wollt ja nur
ein patch day und dieser ganze wir haben
es satt wir wollen das nicht mehr wir
wollen ernsthaft darüber reden wie wir
emissionen die und auch da hat sie ein
punkt nachweislich trotz paris trotz
kyoto trotz allem nach wie vor steigen
steigen und steigen
wir wollen dass das ein ende hat und wir
wollen von euch jetzt antworten haare
klare anzupassen
[Applaus]
die mechanismen von politik
ich weiß nicht ob die politik man von
der politik sprechen ich sage die
mechanismen von erotik heute sind sowie
haben wir haben eher mehr über
unterschiedliche dinge wollten lieber
sprechen wir streiten über die frage
schulpflicht ja oder nein
jetzt führen wir gerade einem medien
eine medien debatte über ein twitter
kann ja auch gerne beiträge leisten zu
dieser debatte
ich verstehe herrn harbeck von den
grünen der irgendwann gesagt hat diese
empörung in mache ich nicht mehr mit
ich schreibe etwas es wird mir das wort
im mund herumgedreht ich kann
nachvollziehen wo andere schlüsse so
jetzt kommen wir zu dem wesentlichen
punkt der debatte klima was er
hasselhoff nicht weiß ist ich bin nicht
der deutsche regierungschef sondern ich
bin angehöriger der opposition
das heißt ich stehe im gegensatz zu der
regierung die gegenwärtig das falsche
tut jetzt kommen wir zum einen punkt
zurück wir müssen in deutschland in der
tat darüber sprechen wie wird effektiv
klimaschutz betrieben und da gibt es
unterschiedliche wege es gibt ein paar
die leute nun den klimawandel dazu
gehöre ich nicht
es gibt ein paar die wollen gar
richtiges übernimmt punkt sind wir doch
längst hinein sind wir in der liga sehen
auch er nicht die regierung macht status
quo und sage ich nochmal mein punkt den
ich wo ich gerade eben unterbrochen
worden bin
die einen sagen ist eine realität die
debatte wird ja geführt drei flüge pro
jahr und mensch und da sage ich dieses
problem sollte man gar nicht kann ja
stellen weil dann können lassen sich
wieder ein einziges mal wirklich dass
sondern sind aber ich merke dass die
dünnhäutig sind bei dem thema das merkt
nach bin ich gern bin ich bin ich gar
nicht ich will noch nicht auf dem einen
punkt erläutern ja unbedingt nach kant
er kritisiert werden ich bin auch nicht
bin heute also mein mann punkt ist wir
führen eine debatte über tatsächlich
doch verbote und subventionen und
verweilen und der gipfel war drei
flugreisen pro person und jahr
was bedeutet dass ganz viele menschen
auch nicht mehr so ohne weiteres ihren
ihren urlaub am mittelmeer machen können
und da ist mein vorschlag geben
ich möchte nicht über verbote sprechen
weil ich glaube dass sich sondern die
menschen dagegen wehren würden was ich
wünsche ist dass wir als europäer zum
beispiel um bei den flugreisen zu
bleiben
dass wir europäer weltweit führend
werden
weil wir als erste das mit wasserstoff
betriebene flugzeug einführen sobald wie
möglich weil es dann möglich ist dass
die menschen ihre freiheit behalten
besichert und hohlstedt 1 punkten was
machen
was wir gerade erleben ist doch sie
haben das jetzt schon mehrfach gesagt
mit diesen drei flugreisen und so weiter
das ist doch abarbeiten sozusagen wieder
am politischen gegner das ist ein
beispiel ja aber sie haben ja zwei mal
sagen
ein anderes beispiel ich würde gerne von
luisa wissen an welchem punkt stehen wir
denn eigentlich haben welchem punkt der
ganzen veranstaltung sind wir denn
eigentlich wie ernst ist denn die
situation tatsächlich die die klima die
klimasituation naja die esma tischer als
ich jemals in der menschheitsgeschichte
war und wir stehen ganz kurz wenige
jahre vielleicht ein zwei jahrzehnte vor
den den schäden die man sich kaum
vorstellen kann wir sind eine
geologische kraft als menschheit
geworden dass es jenseits von dem was
wir uns vorstellen können ich habe
letzte woche mit den kollegen vom
potsdam-institut lange darüber
gesprochen mit greta und das ist
beeindruckend die schildern dass sie
sich vor fünf jahren noch nicht hätten
vorstellen können welche punkte jetzt
sind da wir ja bei gott sei dank keine
klimaleugner hier sind glaube ich können
wir heute auf die politische ebene
kommen weil das ist ja gerade so
gespannt was die helena dazu sagen
ich glaube ihr problem ist zum einen
dass sie in der debatte die eigentlich
sehr konstruktiv sein könnte als
allererstes reinschmeißen worüber sie
nicht reden wollen nein nein nein ich
möchte nicht mehr verbote reden ok ihm
reden bin ich über verbote hängen sich
nicht an einem politiker auf die
irgendwie mit welchen flug onkels
kontingenten anfängt können wir uns
sparen lassen sie uns konstruktiv werden
sie sagen super losen klimaschutz wissen
sie was da der der entscheidende faktor
ist und ich bin mir nicht sicher ob dies
bisher so ganz in der konsequenz
verstanden haben sagen sie muss wenn wir
über klimaschutz sprechen und über das
pariser abkommen von dem sie also ein
verfechter sind dann sprechen wir über
ein ganz klares emissionsbudget was sie
für deutschland haben ob das denn frauen
gebaut 7 gigatonnen das sind die grenze
ist es nicht behandelbar dass es nicht
irgendwie zum kompromiss stehen das ist
eine ganz ganz fest emissionsgrenzen
wenn wir so weitermachen wie bisher sind
wir in ungefähr neun jahren da das wäre
der business as usual check für
deutschland dass die idee dass 1,5 grad
ziel zu heulen
ihr 15 das wäre so mit einer guten
wahrscheinlichkeit so was wie 1,7 grad
drüber leichten ich habe mich gerade
noch mal bei den profis versichert dass
es im endeffekt wo wir stehen
das heißt wenn sie klimapolitik machen
wollen meinetwegen auch liberale
klimapolitik ist dem planeten egal ob es
lieber radio der sozialdemokratisch ist
legen sie los aber sie haben eine grenze
gesetzt sie haben ganz klares limit wenn
sie von technologieoffenheit sprechen
machen sie das aber das muss in der
konsequenz und auch mit einem
gerechtigkeit fraktion natürlichen
stehen die innerhalb von diesen grenzen
bleiben gut mund zu lamentieren was wir
denn alles nicht wollen und dass ihr
habt alle auf ihren ruhm haben auf
twitter und das wir bloß nicht über
flugverbote sprechen sollen bringt uns
da keinen zentimeter weiter was wir
brauchen sind echte vorbilder sind echte
ideen ist in konzepte und sorry das war
der fdp gerade überhaupt nicht zu finden
ist das ein ganz ganz kurz am rhein ist
das etwas wenn man sich mit der fdp mann
beschäftigt die fdp war
interessanterweise die erste partei
überhaupt die ein ökologisches programm
aufgelegt hat die erste überhaupt wann
war das in den 69 so erste
umweltminister war hat sicherlich kennt
schon so er hat das umweltbundesamt
gegründet und genau das
immissionsschutzgesetz was wir heute
haben kommt alles von da genau 50 jahre
her
was ist daraus geworden ist dass etwas
von dem sie sagen
und das mache ich jetzt gar nicht
politisch ja da haben wir alle fehler
gemacht ich denke zum beispiel auch an
die csu in bayern
die glaube ich auch überrascht worden
von der heftigkeit von der dringlichkeit
mit der dieses ökologische thema
plötzlich auf der agenda war das ist
einer der gründe warum die menschen in
bayern sich plötzlich so in scharen
abgewandt haben von der csu will jedoch
eigentlich dass ökonomie angeht und
hervorragenden job für dieses land
machen aber die ökologie ist das
brennende thema und deswegen hast du
plötzlich diese unglaublich grünen
zustimmungswerte es gibt einen
interessanten chart den haben uns mal
mal raus geholt
ich weiß nicht ob die regie denn jetzt
vorliegen hat der das im grunde noch
einmal verdeutlicht schauen sie mal dies
diese kurve würde ich ihnen gerne mal
zeigen gelb sie anders unten ist die fdp
und die grüne kurve ist natürlich die
kurve der grünen partei wenn sie mal
genau hinschauen wann die
zustimmungswerte für die grünen dermaßen
hoch gegangen sind es wirklich
interessant
das war der moment in dem wir diesen
wahnsinnig heißen sommer hatten letztes
jahr das war der sommer als als jedem
plötzlich klar wurde
da passiert gerade irgendwas waldbrände
in kalifornien wir hatten verheerende
katastrophen in china und so weiter und
so weiter und plötzlich gibt es genau
diesen punkt der rote kreis ist übrigens
der punkte an dem sie haben in jamaika
platzen lassen das ist nur fürs
protokoll
aber seitdem ist im grunde bei der fdp
vor nichts passiert wenn ich diese kurve
sie würde ich sagen
haben sie da vielleicht eine chance
liegen lassen also wollen wir das über
umfragen sprechen nicht über umfragen es
geht darum zu erfüllen diese kurven
seismograph die zeit ganz offenbar was
die sehnsucht da draußen wirklich ist
und was die leute offenbar wirklich
wichtig weil sein lassen wir uns doch
damit beginnen die umfrage
zu verändern indem ich auf frau neubauer
antworte weil wir haben tatsächlich den
gleichen ansatzpunkt sie sagt ja ja sie
sagen ja wir haben eine bestimmte menge
co2 die wendung ausstossen dürfen um das
pariser klimaschutzabkommen zu erreichen
deutschland für deutschland und dem
stimme ich zu
und gegenwärtig machen wir eine politik
die versucht sehr planwirtschaftlich in
jedem detail bereich zu schauen
und deshalb lassen wir chancen liegen
also ich muss noch mal sagen wir machen
nichts um die gebäude energetisch zu
sanieren damit wir effizienter heizen da
machen wir nichts wir konzentrieren uns
auf windräder und auf elektroautos aber
nicht auch den strom in den süden zu
transportieren so erhalten 200 rassen
nicht genau die hat nicht bauen
wir konzentrieren uns zum beispiel auf
das elektroauto und wir konzentrieren
uns auf erneuerbare energien
wenn wir ihr modell ernst nehmen bin
ganz bei nicht mehr sagt die
wissenschaft genau das sagt das potsdam
institut mit janina und die profis
anders die profis einige andere leute
mit profis meine ich eben die leute die
technisch umsetzen aber egal wie geht es
um folgendes wenn wir das ernst nehmen
es gibt eine menge co2 die wir noch
verbrauchen dürfen aber nicht mehr
dann ist doch egal wo wir das co2
einsparen ob wir das einsparen beim auto
oder ob wir es ein stativ einem gebäude
und genau diese wände müssen wir in
deutschland machen weg von der klima
planwirtschaft wo leute die vielleicht
gar nicht genau die technischen
zusammenhänge kennen detail
entscheidungen treffen diene dazu dass
wir sagen egal wo hauptsache es wird co2
eingespart und jetzt erreichen wir
dadurch folgendes ich glaube wir
erreichen dann ihre co2 ziele die auch
meine sind die klimaziele von paris aber
wir verhindern in deutschland gelb
westen proteste wie in frankreich
denn das gehört zur wahrheit das ist die
andere seite die ja jetzt future bei uns
und wir haben die gelb besten proteste
in frankreich weil damit auch harte
ökonomische konflikte begründet sind und
deshalb will ich einen weg finden zum
klimaschutz werden weil diese die
wirtschaft erklärten sie meinen geld
besten proteste deswegen weil die
ausgelöst worden sind durch erhöhte
benzin absatz durch besteuerung höheren
besteuerung von benzin und ich glaube
dass da etwas tun muss ja und wir
brauchen auch eine transformation beim
verkehr
aber trotzdem ist es glaube ich es
notwendig dass wir anders denken als
bisher wir erreichen die klimaziele
nicht um das ist zu teuer bei uns beides
müsste nicht sein
lisa
[Applaus]
dass mit der sanierung beschäftigen
möchte da bin ich tatsächlich bei ihnen
ansonsten ist aber recht unsauber
argumentiert denn das problem ist ja
oder die große gefahr ist beim
klimaschutz ja mehr das dann nicht
sozialverträglich ist was
klimaschutzmaßnahmen finde gesellschaft
sind sind in aller erster instanz
erstmal ganz große herausforderungen
sozialer art das heißt was sind
maßnahmen die um verteilungsmechanismen
mitdenken
das hat jetzt aber nicht wie sie sagen
was mit detailfragen zu tun sondern mit
den groben ausrichtung von die wollen
wir klimaschutz gemeinsam gestalten wie
wir es angehen und wie bringen wir so
viele akteure wie gemacht gemeinsam an
einen tisch und befassen uns in aller 1
in aller gemeinsamkeit als gesellschaft
mit dieser herausforderung umgehen dass
auch an was da nicht hilft sind ist die
beschwörung von das kommt nun ein wer
wagt es planwirtschaftlich obwohl das an
der stelle sehr leerer begriff ist zu
agieren dann beschwört irgendwelche gelb
besten protest gebrauch
was auch nicht hilft es dass mehr aktiv
das klimaschutz immer irgendwie mit
verzicht einen herrn kommt wenn er nicht
absolut markt gelegt ist und eine dritte
sache noch wir müssen in allen
teilbereichen emissionen einsparen wir
müssen bis 20 35 10 sein
das heißt wir müssen aus der kohle raus
wir müssen im verkehr wahnsinnig viel
tun
wir müssen uns mobilitätskonzepten mit
der agrarwirtschaft beschäftigen
da kommen sie nicht so leicht raus zu
sagen wir gucken da wo es leicht ist
vielleicht doch
also ich würde eine anekdote erzählen es
gab ja jetzt diese kohle kommission raus
aus braunen steinen und innerhalb einer
woche hatte ich an edenhofer den sie
kennen dem klimaforscher aus potsdam mit
meinem büro zu gast und den den chef
interessenvertreter der deutschen
energiewirtschaft und das war für mich
eine paradoxe woche denn der
klimaforscher sagte das ergebnis der
kohle kommission ist falsch weil es zu
planwirtschaftlich ist und der chef der
energiebranche der vertreter sagte wir
sind zufrieden weil wir bekommen hohe
entschädigungen und deshalb glaube ich
dass das spiel der klimaforscher sagt
falsch weil planwirtschaftlich und teuer
und die energie brauchen gesagt wir sind
zufrieden weil die alten kraftwerke
würden sowieso abschalten bekommen aber
jetzt geld
vom staat noch dafür haben sie noch zeit
das ist schon deshalb glaube ich wir
sind obwohl sie bei den grünen
organisiert sind wir sind in der sache
gar nicht so weit auseinander okay was
sie gerne ja gesagt habe ich ja für den
angeführten klimapolitik kann auch
liberal sein
ich denke sie haben und das zeigen diese
grafen von anguckt haben ist an
entscheidenden stellen verpasst eine
konstruktive debatte einzusteigen sich
loszulösen von ihren vorbehalten
gegenüber grünen politik oder
mechanismen die den ich liberal genug
sind für ihr verständnis da wäre ein
riesengroßes gestaltungs feld gewesen wo
man sich auch mit mit liberalen ideen
hätte einbringen können das ist nicht
richtig dass das lauteste was sie von
ihnen gehört haben ist besagter tweet
was an der stelle ob gemacht haben hat
der rechner samt leicht gemacht wurde
aber gesagt noch an einem anderen punkt
noch sehr nahe beieinander und das wäre
sozusagen jetzt der versöhnliche
abschluss auch mit blick auf die schule
auf die frage sollte man schulschwänzer
oder nicht es gibt einen sehr
interessanten ausschnitt ein kleines
filmdokument aus ihren jugendtagen
herrlich bitte das ist was für eine
einschätzung eine einschätzung zum thema
schule schauen mal ganz kurz rein
bitteschön
ich bin christian lindner und wir
besuchen beide gemeinsam diagramm stufe
13 des städtischen gymnasiums in
wermelskirchen was ich würds zumindest
die fdp meine politische heimat
christian und christopher sind echte
durch starter und immer voll im stress
in der geliehenen limousine wird
gearbeitet der kunde wartet schon
schule ist für die beiden trotz abitur
umgeben sache wichtiger ist es pr
konzepte zu verkaufen am kunden die ihre
väter sein könnten
sie war sehr aktiv sind wenn sie
leistungsbereit sind sehr motiviert sind
wenn sie auch mal mit krawatte in die
schule gehen müssen dann hat das
auswirkungen auf den pädagogisches klima
meint man in die schule gehen christian
und christopher sowieso nur noch weil
sie das abiturzeugnis wollen beibringen
kann ihnen dort niemand was und
eigentlich hätten sie besseres zu tun
wenn man in der schule sitzt und man
sitzt seine zeit ab weiß dass man
telefonieren den kunden besuchen oder
arbeit erledigen müsste dann kommt man
sich so vor als sei die zeit durch den
schredder gelaufen da kann man doch
schluss
[Applaus]
denn neben den ausschnitt haben sie aber
am letzten besuch vor einem jahr schon
aber so gut wie heute hat er noch nie
gepasst ich habe ich eine bluse auf 30
fand ich einfach nur lustig weil ihre
auffassung zum thema schule ist der von
looser hornig so weit weg also ich hab
mir ich habe jedenfalls nicht geschwänzt
aber sie haben andere setzen und durch
die stadt der gedreht was 18-jährige
sagen
darüber darf man sich aber vorsicht
jetzt dünnes eis ja ganz praktisch 40
glaub ich sehe es ein bisschen anders
als damals ja aber trotzdem ich stehe
dazu ich war an 200 jungen ist doch ein
guthaben sie brauchten das geld es ist
alles in ordnung
es ist das